the front lines of this conflict cut
along the horizon but the war is still
very close to this village which sits
uneasily above the sea of azov
captain maksum chuck shows me where the
shell landed
most of the people who live here have
fled and it is easy to understand why
walking around here
it's pretty unnerving it's a spooky
place to be
on the one hand you look out to see it's
a picture of tranquility to my left and
right there are holiday homes dachshunds
but it's deserted now it last came under
attack in 2016
but in the last few hours there have
been
shells coming in
it's not surprising that most people
left years ago
a few hardy souls remain
jenna is one of them she says she fears
for her life and is desperate to leave
achilles
the war does feel like it's getting
nearer here and the shoreline would be a
likely target of any invasion
and whilst we were there shells started
landing again and we were running for
safety
it just shows how quickly things can
change here
we were outside filming
really calm
there had been shells that had come in
this morning
but again it
it had gone quiet everything felt very
very normal but we've just had to come
in here to take cover
because there's been incoming mortar
fire
the soldiers here fear the increase in
attacks may be a prelude to a wider
assault and it may come soon
this is a country very much on the edge
waiting nervously for what comes next
alex rossi sky news near mario pool